you ever played in a Immaculate grid bro
I haven't do you know a whole lot about
baseball so that means we're not about
to do very good 200 plus hit seasons and
30 30. ain't no like clues or anything
no that's it Barry Bonds I don't know if
you ever had 200 hits hey what about
that second one B Gordon
let's go oh point three three thousand
hits and had a 200 hit season I mean
Ichiro solid 40 Homer 3 000 hits
poolhost definitely poolhost yeah 40
Homer Gold Glove you think Griffey ooh
might be the solid one I mean a gold
glove 100 artery eyes that could be I
mean I've done that let's do it all
right let's see hello oh yeah I made it
I got top left the CUNY right all right
but bottom right what about uh Mickey
Cabrera right yeah it's got to be very
Bonds in which one the 40 the 40 ah who
is the top right of course